si on pense que sophie marceau à une
douce vie calme et fastueuse il faut
parfois faire la différence entre
fiction et réalité car si la crise est
plutôt habitué à tourner dans les
comédies romantiques ces dernières
années de sa vie de famille c'était pour
le moins transformée en drame
alors qu'il ya quatre ans elle perdait
son ex compagnon le réalisateur polonais
andrzej zulawski sophie marceau devait
dans le même temps assumer la descente
aux enfers de vincent le fils qu'elle a
eu avec lui un jeune homme de 21 ans
très perturbé par la disparition de son
père qui avait traversé des périodes
très sombre jusqu'à une crise de démence
inouïe dont la crise avait été témoin et
qui avait contraint le jeune homme à une
hospitalisation en établissement
psychiatrique
les aujourd'hui tout va mieux trois ans
après cette période compliquée vincent
aujourd'hui âgé de 24 ans semble avoir
réussi à surmonter ses démons
le 10 décembre dernier il a publié le
charlatan et autres poèmes un recueil
qui fait la fierté de sa mère comment ne
pas dire mon émotion lorsque je lis ces
mots c'est bouleversant et magnifique
merci à la vie à son pouvoir de guérison
par la création et à l'amour d'être
toujours plus fort que tout merci
vincent les mots d'une mère aussi
touchant que sincère
est ce que ça vous tout ça est ce que
c'est difficile d'être pour vous à votre
avis le fils d'une immense star comme ça
benjamin on sait que toi tu es tu viens
d'une famille alors je vous le grand
père de benjamin c'était yves montand
ils vont temps c'était une des plus
grandes stars françaises vraiment il
s'étonne de pas comme depardieu c'est
simone signoret aussi la faire venir
c'est aujourd'hui voilà cc voilà c'est
monstrueux
moi j'ai été très protégé je remercie
mes parents mes grands parents
moi j'avais était pote avec guillaume
depardieu pour qui c'était beaucoup plus
compliqué c'est pas facile parce
qu'effectivement on en a un exemple et
pour les enfants de stars moi j'en
connais quelques-uns c'est vrai que
c'est souvent très compliqué de
s'affirmer d'exister moi j'ai eu cette
chance ils m'ont protégé totalement
jusqu'à très tard jusqu'à ou 12-13 ans
j'étais totalement à l'écart de tout
j'avais même pas conscience de quitter
mes grands parents
c'est beaucoup plus tard j'ai réalisé
pour avoir franchement c'est presqu'en
ma grand-mère est morte que j'ai compris
ce qui avait été leur leur vie ce qu'ils
avaient fait vraiment donc moi j'aime
vraiment grâce à dieu ils m'ont protégé
mais certains ratios si vous n'êtes pas
déphasé parce que mine de rien vous
voyez vous avez eu des saignements star
venir chez vous c'est vrai que vous
voilà vous avez eue ils n'ont rien vous
voyez votre grand père qui était
extrêmement connu votre grand mère aussi
il était vraiment gérant est élevé dans
le respect de la vie du travail ggp a
été super sympa et et supra gâtés on m'a
toujours dit chaque chose se mérite
quand je travaille mal de l'école on
punissait non mais c'est à paris qu'on
mais je me suis là noël ce n'est pas un
bon bulletin n'est pas de cadeau que
tiraient partout ah oui donc ça mais ça
marrant ça m'a rendu service j'ai cet
appareil est que les enfants mais ça n'a
pas marché le jaune
c'est le seul jour où il avait pas de
cadeaux à noël mais ça a été plus
compliqué pour mes enfants par exemple
pour mes enfants c'était beaucoup
beaucoup plus compliqué parce que le
papa et la télé tous les jours et sert à
rien en dessous faire excusez moi il ya
des mecs qui devait agir le rouergue
je dirais qu'il prépare son pique nique
de dubaï article à la bouche en tôle
d'aluminium --qui projet qu'on va être
compliqué j'imagine pour bages à masquer
son comparse y est toujours le succès
j'entame moins bien réussi ton bouton
grand-père et cetera même si ta réussite
est toujours moins bien que quelqu'un
qui est prestigieux donc c'est plus
compliqué parce que vous vous auriez
aimé et vous aussi je vous pose la
question
être le fils d'une immense star ou
est-ce que ça vous aurait fait peur
voilà moi par exemple je jouerai je
n'aurais pas aimé franchement c'est
super ça doit être compliqué voilà
répondu benhaim vous fassiez on sait que
c'est compliqué l'exposition parce que
quand on quand on rencontre aussi quand
on regarde tous cas cela bois mais même
quand on rencontre le succès oui on le
rencontre à 20 ans c'est une rencontre à
40 ans garbure moins armé [ __ ] de leur
consacrer à mon grand dam des tarifs du
gaz allaient fermer les yeux quelle
lourde
je t'aime et tu arrives à savoir pour
quelle raison les gens sont avec toi si
c'est parce que tu es douce d'une
famille bien sûr problème de riche à son
fils d'une star du thème bagdad
les coûts connaissent et marvin martin
son père c'était une immense star eh ben
je peux vous pouvez vous dire sans
rigoler le mec l'ipad aux arrivées dans
un trou donc je vous jure que c'est vrai
j'étais fils de rené la taupe
moi j'aurais pu j'aurais détesté tawfir
d'une grande dune d'une grande star et
que vous vous trompez sur un point
précis c'est que toutes les vedettes
elles ont des états d'âme quand elle
tourne quand elle tourne pas elle son
père d'échec cd intelligent frémissant
qui sont fortement repliés sur eux mêmes
par moment et elle avoue su trouver sa
place quand on était gosses là dedans
souvent compliqué la raison non mais
c'est un pote rachid son père il est
hyper connus jure que c'est vrai voilà
je le vois il fait la vaisselle il fait
des trucs sont rigoler c'est rachid
l'épongé à mi distance dans la société
où on s a aidé énormément d'avoir des
parents qui sont connus pour réussir je
suis d'accord avec jean michel c'est une
haine incommensurable on peut faire de
longues études parce qu'on a des parents
fortunés
on baigne dans un milieu artistique
qu'on a envie d'être artiste où elle a
des difficultés mais c'est une aide pas
lapointe les trois quarts ce droit dans
les arbres et haies avec s'arrêter avec
ses idées reçues de rigoler arrêtez moi
c'est l'évêque j'étais avec pikachu son
fils au docteur moi je partage pas parce
que parfois quand elle est en vedette
benjamin il peut le dire ils sont en
voyage ils sont en tournage et il te
manque le père ou la mère ce même si tu
te mets ou s'ils ont tâché d'être sa
part et oui c'est comme ça sans fin mars
aux alpes en galère d'argent sophie
marceau sont si le papa du gamin là qui
était réalisateur pas en galère d'argent
il est parti en asile psychiatrique vous
rendez compte
les partis en asie en psychiatrie et à
des enfants de chauffeur livreur de
n'importe qui sont heureux comme tout
avec leur papa parce qu'ils mangent avec
eux avec son père tous les soirs mais ça
vaut rien sans rien avoir à faire les
enfants si de chauffe il est rare qu'ils
ont des problèmes psychiatriques et
comme tout comme l'année passée m'a
passé regrette pas parce que tu as de
l'argent avec ton père il est connu et
tamar est connue de tous
les études pour les adultes a dit moi je
pense qu'il ya du bon et du mauvais des
deux côtés parce que parce qu'au quai là
il s'est drogué asile psychiatrique tout
ça mais chez des personnes un peu plus
un peu plus dans la merde ça peut
arriver aussi
et je pense que c'est chacun son clip en
fait même s'ils voient passer par an et
qui voyage etc
peut-être que les petits qui veut ça et
peut-être que celui qu'avait l'argent du
décret que ses parents équipe ça donc on
perd on n'en parle plus parce que
forcément comme celle des enfants de
stars on a l'impression que c'est et on
en parle plus parce que voilà ça
intéresse tout le monde moi mais je
pense que leur temps en temps ils se
mêlent vraiment l'impression que les
jeux et jouets jouer au loto ils ont
pour but scan pas mondiaux pauvres
deviennent pas voter c'est une maman qui
se bat pour que son fils allait mieux ça
me touche et je vois pas pourquoi on
ramène le débat à l'argent même moi j'ai
pas vu des enfants trois garçons ça me
parle et je sais que tu vas le grand il
a 18 ans il est parti faire ses études à
l'étranger et j'ai peur pour lui parce
que je sais qu'il ya énormément de
drogue maintenant qui circule de plus en
plus voilà donc ça me touche plus que ce
débat d'argent pas d'argent l'abrégé
appel à jamais moi ma fille est restée à
8 heures du matin pour aller au taf
parce qu'elles travaillent au bloc
opératoire elle a suivi un cursus normal
quand même
pas regarder ce qu'en pensent les
personnes du voile à kara qui s'annonce
et voilà vous avez non ya pas mal voilà
bah moi j'aurais pas aimé
moi je vous dis la vérité je vois pas
aimé